hey everyone Spencer here and today
we're looking at Ghost Recon wildlands
the first mission we're going to show
you guys is a hostage rescue mission
what other missions would you like to
see leave a comment down below if you
enjoy this video feel free to like and
subscribe for more so let's get started
starts let's go the drone is up yo
cartel gunmen in the field spawning
another tango
I have my I got a third target I got one
in the field
[Music]
target mark to keep an eye on your
background
[Music]
[Music]
that's a guillotine free to fill it
[Music]
back and re would keep them until you're
late take the largest
the divide what is left between you and
your
we are you would not rain when you have
so you would be left with barely any way
best way
increased and insanity know that the
enemy if singles in the second army blow
the key back just knock it down another
shitty be careful c'est bien disfruta on
a second nie toes escucha bien well
you're no piranha nature and it's
undoubtedly easier
[Music]
history
that came to do the barn good shooting
let's clean up and move on
there's a weapons case over here I'm
gonna do them SI leader becky awesome i
can put this to you
you
[Music]
[Music]
with you
are you Amaru what's left of him anyway
come on getting you out of here
[Music]
I got it i'll fly
[Music]
where are you taking me back here friend
entonces park at erica's make it till
wed a midi toes extranjeros tagrapha
dmca or
this is it
yo got a weapons case here
I've been wanting one of these
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
are you hurt ah Santa Blanca is not the
most races of hosts least Oh Cass these
demons are questioning me let us say the
talk of love was enough to make me from
it but their methods were not we're not
we're their names URI and pollito see
Geordie boys dog these are the [ __ ]
that tortured Ricky Sandoval was when
you questioned him I want them bad we
only sell run-of-the-mill sikarios when
we freedom Armin but I haven't seen you
do you believe in at least three days
maybe four I don't know where they are
now we need more Intel will search every
village in camp until we find something
somebody's got to know something gather
documents hack computers interrogate
hostile lieutenants talk to civvies
whatever it takes we'll turn over every
Rock
you
heads up Bowman's file a urien pulido is
coming through
that's the Ron Dennis there were four
people in the room the night DEA agent
Ricky Sandoval was murdered el sueño the
head of the Santa Blanca cartel Ricky
and the last two relay Yuri and Oakland
ito Yuri and pulido met at a poor
state-run hospital in Chiapas where El
palito was doing his residency and lay
Yuri worked as a nurse it was love at
first sight from the first moment their
eyes met they were inseparable a love
like no other
one day a boot on named la plaga what
did he do all shout out it was touch and
go for a while but Yuri and pallida were
able to save his life laplata was
grateful he showered them with gifts
invitations to the most exclusive
parties in a new car and after a while
laplata made Yuri and paleta the
personal medical staff of the Santa
Blanca cartel but that was in their main
job CTA and pulido know about the human
body they know how much pain a person
can endure before he'll die they know
how to keep a person alive and wake so
they can feel the pain and most of all
they know how to inflict that's what
they do in a taco problems when Santa
Blanca capture some whenever fuses talk
the URI and El palito make him talk they
break people like I said there were four
people in the room in my Ricky sanibel
was murdered sueno Ricky Yuri and
polluted they kept Ricky alive while
sueno tortured him non-stop for 47 hours
straight
they broke Ricky Sandoval then sueno
executed
you
urien el pollito there are a key part of
santa blanca security operation remember
to check out Bowman